when Elon Musk purchased Twitter a year
ago the federal government and its
allies embarked on maybe the single most
desperate and obvious campaign to
destroy a private citizen that's been
undertaken in this country in modern
history not since Julian Assange began
exposing war crimes by the Pentagon has
the left turned on one of its Heroes so
quickly and with so much vitriol like
Julian Assange uh musk was a catalyst
for public discussions that our leaders
simply do not want us to be having
Twitter under musk allows everyone to
speak directly to the people in power it
allows average Americans to say what
they're actually thinking free of
censorship at least for the most part
and that's the one thing that the
federal government simply cannot permit
so Elon Musk became a villain virtually
overnight the turn uh was not exactly
convincing indeed it's difficult to
overstate the extent of the absurdity of
this particular smear campaign they
really aren't even trying to hide it Joe
Biden's SEC launched an investigation
into whether musk was trying to build
himself a quote unquote last house using
money from Tesla which he
single-handedly transformed from near
bankruptcy into the most profitable car
company on the planet meanwhile the doj
sued musk's company for not hiring
enough refugees which was so absurd on
its face that a judge recently shut the
whole thing down and Regulators working
for the State of California who have
never produced anything remotely useful
in their lives and don't even pretend to
went after musk because his assembly
plants are hot beds for white supremacy
because some employees overheard a
racial slur or something supposedly
at the same time the media reassured us
again and again that Twitter was on the
verge of failing and it was going to
collapse it would collapse during the
midterm elections they told us last year
now none of these attacks were really
effective because they were either
obviously false or too far removed from
Elon Musk himself the media could claim
that some random Tesla Factory had
racist graffiti in the bathroom but
linking such a heinous fake crime to
Elon Musk is not very easy to do so for
the past year the forces of censorship
have been grinding away trying and
utterly failing to land a kill shot on
Elon Musk but all the while they've been
waiting waiting for the perfect moment
if they think they found a perfect
moment it doesn't pan out they're
waiting for the real perfect moment to
pounce well last week these operatives
sensed that they'd finally had their
opening it All Began on November 15th
when uh a a video which we'll play for
you in a second appeared on Twitter
which is now known as X of course it's
uh from a group called the foundation to
combat anti-Semitism which was founded
by the billionaire NFL owner Robert
Craft and here is the video
watch I saw what you've been
posting Hitler was
right I didn't teach you
that
you hide behind your screen spewing all
this hatred and
ugliness you got something you want to
say get out of the truck and say it to
their
[Music]
faces
okay so the thrust of this ad is pretty
simple an older white guy is upset that
his young white son is going going
online and telling people that Hitler
did nothing wrong uh but this white kid
is too cowardly to say any of that to
the group of Jewish people walking by
and the ad concludes by claiming that
70,000 posts have been made online uh
since last year praising Hitler uh which
were led to believe is is uh very
shocking because apparently this is the
only kind of insane thing that people
post on the internet I mean you clearly
could not find 70,000 posts saying that
white people are evil or that the world
is flat or that men can have babies that
would be unheard of the internet's not a
place where people just randomly say
crazy things not at all regardless uh
right away there are some deeper
criticisms you can make in response to
this ad for one thing you might point
out that the advertisement's choice of
actors is pretty conspicuous all the bad
guys once again of course are white we
see this phenomenon in pretty much every
advertisement these days all state in
particular goes out of its way to convey
that white guys have a propensity for
carjacking Which flies in the face of
literally every crime statistics
statistic that's been recorded since we
had automobiles in this country and in
this case once again the casting is
absurd the reality as unpleasant as it
may be is that uh black people commit a
wildly disproportionate amount of
attacks against Jewish people on the
basis of their religion in New York City
for example black people are the salance
and roughly 42% of the documented hate
crime attacks against Jews in cases
where the race of the attacker is known
this is a city by the way where blacks
make up less than a quarter of the
population and by the way these
statistics don't account for how many of
the white attackers have Middle Eastern
ancestry for example so hearing this you
might object well just because they
chose a white guy to play anti-semite in
this one advertisement doesn't mean that
they think all white people are
anti-semitic they're not trying to send
any kind of message but if that's true
you have to ask where are the ads from
the foundation to combat anti-Semitism
that address nonwhite people who are
anti-semitic who actually committing
violent crimes where's there ad where a
black or Muslim father has to give the
talk to his child and tell him not to go
around beating Jews up on the street
well there isn't one this group has
never made an ad like that I checked and
it doesn't exist and that's why and that
this is true of many of these kinds of
groups that talk about the uh the uh uh
problems of anti-Semitism they're very
very targeted in the the uh people that
they uh direct that message to and
that's why in response to that video we
just played and referring to this trend
of left-wing Jewish groups demonizing
white people which is easily observable
and therefore something you're not
supposed to talk about I guess an
anonymous user on X wrote this quote
quoting now okay Jewish communities have
been pushing the exact kind of
dialectical hatred against whites that
they claim to want people to stop using
against them I'm deeply disinterested in
giving the tiniest now about Western
Jewish populations coming to the
disturbing realization that those hordes
of minorities that support flooding
their country don't exactly look like
them too much you want truth said to
your face there it is now Elon Musk
apparently saw that comment which was
under that video that we just played and
he agreed with it and here's what musk
posted in response you have said the
actual truth so just expressing
agreement now musk then elaborated in a
follow-up post about an hour and a half
later musk wrote quote the ADL unjustly
attacks the majority of the West despite
the majority of the West supporting
Jewish people in Israel this is because
they cannot by their own tenants
criticize the minority groups who are
their primary threat it is not right and
needs to stop now one another poster
explained that not all Jewish
communities are involved in this kind of
race hatred musk answer quote you're
right that this does not extend to all
Jewish communities but it is also not
just limited to the
ADL so that is musk explaining what he
is talking about which by the way is
also something you're not allowed to do
these days so if you say something and
then and everyone goes oh you said that
you must really mean
this it's it's too late for you to come
back and say well no that's not what I
meant here's what I meant let let me as
the person who said the thing let me
explain what I meant because I'm the
only one who can be an authority on what
I meant when I said something I'm the
only one who is in my own mind and
understands my own
intentions and that should be the end of
it if somebody says something and
everyone misinterprets it oh you must
really mean this and then that person
comes back and says no I didn't mean
that here's what I actually meant that
should be the end of the conversation
the one single Authority on Earth who
can speak to that person's motivations
has spoken and so that's it there's
nothing else to be said but of course
that's not the way it works now and uh
but we know that everything um about
what musk wrote is clearly
reasonable you know about the ADL and so
on that doesn't mean you have to agree
with him but his arguments make sense
they're logical they comport with all
the data we've seen and it's the kind of
thing we should be able to talk about
but large corporations in the federal
government don't want you to have
interesting conversations like this
they're forbidden instead they want you
to shut up and Obey so one after the
other every major media outlet from the
supposedly conservative Wall Street
Journal and Fox News to hardle MSNBC and
CNN lined up to accuse musk of
anti-Semitism this week they accused him
of hating Jews because he criticized a
subset of Jews for doing something that
they're obviously doing which is pushing
a left-wing agenda here's uh CBS news
for example Tech billionaire Elon Musk
is under Fire for spreading anti-semitic
and racist hate to his 160 million
followers on X formerly known as Twitter
Disney is just becoming the latest
Advertiser to flee the social media
platform out of fear that their ads will
appear next to hate speech cbs's Nancy
ctis is at the White House where the
Biden Administration today condemned the
promotion of what it called hideous
anti-semitic
lies the latest Firestorm sparked by
Elon Musk on his social media site X is
now threatening to spread to his other
companies including SpaceX and electric
car maker Tesla as investors openly Muse
about okay well you'll notice and that
ad goes on over that uh ad that that
report which is really an ad goes on for
a while and but nowhere in the CBS
report do they provide any context from
mus for Marks they don't show you the
advertisement he was responding to nor
do they show you his follow-up posts
which make it clear exactly who and what
he's criticizing and why he's
criticizing them as Elon stated when he
says Jewish communities he means Jewish
organizations like the ADL and it's
obvious that organizations like the ADL
and the foundation to combat
anti-Semitism have been pushing a
far-left agenda as I've already outlined
that is not in
dispute
but even if Elon had meant Jewish
communities in the broader sense which
he didn't apparently because again the
one single person who can speak to his
own motivations and intentions is him
and he's already said what he meant but
even if he had meant that he would still
be correct it is simply a fact that the
Jewish demographic in this country is
predominantly liberal not all of them
obviously but a majority in 20 in 2020
Pew found that seven in 10 Jewish adults
identify with the Democratic party or
lean towards it you know and
conservatives also often point out that
black voters largely vote Democrat which
means that they are voting for The Very
people who have spent Generations
destroying their communities by refusing
to enforce the law putting dangerous
criminals back on the street and so on
just go for a walk and sellma sometime
after dark if you doubt that now it
should not be considered outrageous or
bigoted to point out either of these
realities they are simply just
realities as a Catholic if somebody
noted that a majority of Catholics in
this country are liberal on social
issues I would not accuse them of
anti-catholic bigotry instead I would
accuse them of saying something that
happens to be true as much as I wish it
wasn't true it is which is why I also
point that out about uh about Catholics
in this country now despite despite the
truth of all of this or maybe because of
it the outraged dog pile continued to
grow the next organization to jump on
top was none other than the White House
Biden's White House put out a statement
claiming that musk was using the same
logic that a mass shooter indorsed
before killing several people at a
synagogue in Pittsburgh in 2018 this is
how seriously the federal government
takes the First Amendment say something
they don't like even if you're a private
citizen and they'll put out a statement
condemning you and Le linking you to a
mass murderer that's how things work in
this free country of ours the holidays
are rapidly approaching but we can find
peace and calm during this busy season
with hallow the number one Christian
Prayer app in the world immerse yourself
in Christmas and Advent prayers
meditation and peaceful Christmas music
starting December 4th join a claim
actors uh Liam niss and Jonathan roomy
for an incredible prayer experience
leading up to Christmas 25 days of
prayer meditation on the writing of CS
Lewis you don't want to miss this hallow
also offers an extensive library of
Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and audio guided
meditations whether you're a season
Bible reader or just starting on your
journey how provides a platform for you
to engage with scripture like never
before the hall app also helps you
connect with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hall.com
Walsh for 3 months free that's hall.com
Walsh next within hours the White
House's Soros funded propagandist at
Media Matters predictably got involved
now you know we like to have fun with
Media Matters here because they act as
our inadvertent PR team by constantly
promoting my show and the other DW shows
in a vain attempt to smear and embarrass
us yet although the People Media Matters
are a bunch of bumbling clowns and
self-defeating clowns at top on the top
of it that doesn't make them any less
hideously evil let's be clear about that
they are an organization that serves no
purpose on Earth other than to defame
and silence conservatives they will lie
they will slander they will take things
wildly out of context uh they will dig
things up from ages ago they will do
whatever they can to destroy you there
is no tactic too low too unethical for
them but they realize that their efforts
to cast all conservative voices out into
the Hinterlands cannot be successful as
long as musk controls one of the biggest
social media platforms which is why he
must be destroyed so Media Matters they
didn't just stop with that one AR
article I mean this this controversy for
them this is like their Super Bowl they
they're so excited they are thrilled and
they see it as their one realistic
chance to take out musk so just a day
after musk's post about ADL and other
Jewish groups Media Matters posted a
lengthy hit piece about X and the point
of this hit piece was to convince
advertisers to drop the platform and
then bankrupt the company and to that
end media matter specifically alleged
that quote as ex-owner Elon Musk
continues his descent into white
nationalist and anti-semitic conspiracy
theories theories his social media
platform has been placing ads for Major
Brands like apple Bravo IBM Oracle and
XFinity next to content that touts Adolf
Hitler and his Nazi party and this hit
piece was followed by dozens of others
if you go to Media Matters homepage
right now you will find that all of
their featured stories are about Elon
it's just one Elon story after another
all over their homepage so predictably
almost as if it was coordinated a bunch
of companies like IBM and Lionsgate and
Paramount and apple responded to this
hitpiece by suspending their ad
campaigns on X they didn't even wait for
musk's response to to Media Matters or
any kind of independent investigation
whatsoever they decided to cut off
musk's entire social media site because
one rabidly left-wing group claimed that
they found some ads next to
objectionable
content but it appears that Media
Matters isn't just writing hit pieces
musk and Executives at X look into what
Media Matters was claiming and in a
statement posted to his account musk
noted that quote to manipulate the
public and advertisers Media Matters
created an alternate account and curated
the post in advertising appearing on the
account's timeline to misinform
advertisers about the placement of their
posts specifically an executive uh later
alleged that quote Media Matters created
three accounts and followed 30 accounts
similar to the ones in the article they
then constantly refreshed the timeline
of post 13 times uh the number of ads
sered to this user as opposed to the
median 15 impression served against the
content in the article out of 5.5
billion sered the whole day points to
the to the fact of how efficient our
model avoids content for advertisers
data wins over allegations so in other
words if it all sounds kind of confusing
Media Matters appears to have engineered
an artificial scenario to slander Elon
Musk and X they didn't approach this
approach this in any kind of impartial
way they weren't trying to gather
information they were trying to write a
malicious hitpiece and cook the data and
they did and they appear to have cost uh
Twitter X millions of dollars because of
it now for conservatives this is a
familiar story this is the part where
the right usually lies down accepts
their scolding from the far left and
goes into hiding all the while begging
their enemies not to call them racist
anymore but for once that's not
happening here after Gathering all this
data that reveals what what Media
Matters has done musk wrote quote the
Split Second Court opens on Monday EXC
Court will be filing a thermonuclear
lawsuit against Media Matters and all
those who colluded in this fraudulent
attack on our company musk added that
he's going after quote their board their
donors their network of dark money all
of them
now um there are a handful of obvious
justifications for a lawsuit byx against
Media Matters for one they appear to
have deliberately interfered with ex's
contractual relationships with his
advertisers using fraud and deceit in
the
process what's may be more interesting
about this lawsuit aside from the
financial ramifications is what x could
learn in Discovery
it' be very interesting to uncover the
potential level of collusion between
Media Matters and all of these corporate
advertisers it would be very interesting
to learn the extent of the Biden
administration's involvement in all of
this mostly it would be great to see
these soulless hacks at Media Matters
get punched back by the richest man on
the planet usually they target people
who don't have the resources to
challenge them in court this is the game
that these people play they have a lot
of resources a lot of money and uh
usually even if they go after someone
who is just like regular Rich it's still
not they don't have nearly enough money
to withstand it or to to to survive any
kind of Court challenge or anything Elon
Musk is the richest man on the planet so
if there's anything he has it's
resources now the truth is that the
system hates musk for a simple reason he
has provided the one major platform in
existence where we can all speak freely
that's why they're coming after him he
committed the cardinal sin of allowing
us to speak in his as far as Media
Matters is concerned this is
unforgivable that's why Elon should as
he's threatened sue them into bankruptcy
and also boot them from his platform
after all they don't believe that
everyone should have access to social
media so for once let's hold them to
their own
standard if we can do that the Media
Matters and its various cutouts will be
destroyed completely they will never
come back and then the adults in this
country can have real conversations
about how to make our cities livable
again livable again we can talk about
whether it's wise to end LLY print money
to fund Foreign Wars and pay for useless
bureaucrats while our currency loses
value by the day we can have all these
conversations and many more all the
conversations that leftist activists
desperately don't want us to
have this was the fight that was
inevitable from the day Elon Musk bought
Twitter and now it's here and we need to
win it hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there